salut aujourd'hui je vous propose une
enquête interactive
enfin le retour sur cette chaîne c'est
vous qui allez faire tous les choix de
la vidéo la durée du jeu est d'environ
10 à 15 minutes et vous allez devoir
m'aider en enquêtant avec moi dans mes
locaux sur une menace qui pèse sur on va
falloir me dépatouiller de tout ça c'est
la quatrième vidéo sur ce concept que je
fais en quatre ans il y avait eu celle
du million il y avait un test de
mentalisme et il y avait eu aussi inclus
de interactif
les trois autres voulaient mettra en
description si jamais vous voulez les
faire après ça donc mené l enquête ça
c'est sûr mais vous allez aussi devoir
faire des choix à chaque fin de vidéo il
y aura toujours des choix à faire c'est
la suite du jeu c'est la suite des
vidéos chacun va suivre son propre
parcours j'ai créé cette enquête en
m'inspirant du nouveau jeu de dontnod
alors déjà dontnod ses cocoricos parce
que c'est français
ils ont créé le jeu twin mirror puis
mirror pour ceux qui me suivent aussi
sur tweets je vous aviez vu que j'avais
fait le jeu en entier
eh bien j'ai parlé de mon idée d'
enquête interactive avec dont claude qui
ont accepté d'être partenaire de cette
vidéo merci à eux
merci twin mirror et twin miroir c'est
quoi c'est l'histoire d'un gars qui
s'appelle sam ixe il rentre dans sa
ville natale basse woods après la mort
tragique de son meilleur pote et ça mais
il a un esprit différent du nôtre
ok il peut quand il veut rentrer
littéralement dans son esprit pour
accéder à son palais mental où sont
stockées ces souvenirs
le palais mental c'est juste ma passion
donc c'est un truc hyper cristallisé où
il ya les souvenirs et il peut les
activer un peu comme il le souhaite mais
il peut faire d'autres choses avec son
palais mentale par exemple il peut grâce
à son esprit analytique émettre des
hypothèses qui vont se superposer un
petit peu la réalité
il va pouvoir tester des hypothèses des
trucs comme ça c'est très stylé et à
l'image c'est juste magnifique donc en
gros sont pas les mentale à plusieurs
facettes qui lui confère un esprit
analytique est logique et on peut
revivre ses souvenirs mais pas que j'ai
par exemple moi adoré les moments où on
ne simule justement les hypothèses avec
les indices qu'on a collecté et qui se
superpose à la réalité et ça c'est
vraiment magnifique
par contre son esprit il est tellement
analytique que sam n'est pas bon du tout
pour l'occasion social genre pas du tout
et doit compter sur l'aide de son double
qu'il est le seul à pouvoir voir et qui
représente son côté empathique et
sociable donc en gros tout au long de
l'aventuré avec sam hill à son double et
quand on doit faire des choix on a
toujours le choix qui est proposée par
le double qui est plus tôt
empathique un choix qui est bon dans les
émotions on va dire et le choix que
ferait sam qui est un peu plus brute un
peu plus analytique et à chaque fois que
vous faites ces choix là ça des vrais
répercussions dans le jeu mais dans
l'immédiat mais aussi dans la suite du
jeu en gros c'est le double qui nous
permet d'avoir une décision sur comment
agir et c'est ce qui fait toute la
saveur du gameplay puisque on vous
demande de prendre des décisions qui ont
un vrai impact sur l'histoire parfois
même beaucoup plus loin dans le jeu bref
c'est un super thriller psychologique
narratif les images sont très belles
également l'ambiance sonore à l'ewf le
jeu est dispo sur pc sur playstation sur
xbox je vous mets un lien dans la
description pour aller sur le site du
jeu mais sachez que tout au long de
l'enquète vous allez aussi peut-être
voir des codes un petit peu partout donc
fouillé bien toutes les ramifications
parce que ses codes ses des codes pour
avoir le jeu gratuitement il y en a 15
au total
et ce sont des codes à utiliser sur pc
uniquement parce que je savais pas quoi
choisir et quand d'autres noda a proposé
de donner des codes je me suis dit on va
prendre les codes pc bon j'espère que
vous êtes prêt l'enquète que vous allez
résoudre dans ma vidéo youtube s'inspire
donc de la capacité de sa rentrée dans
son palais mental c'est sur ce levier là
qu'on va jouer sur le levier des
décisions moi j'ai trouvé ça génial vous
aurez donc l'occasion de rentrer dans ma
tête pour trouver des indices pour
remettre votre hypothèse et pour revivre
mes souvenirs est-ce que vous êtes prêts
est-ce que vous avez 10 à 15 minutes
devant vous notez que pour jouer vous
aurez à la fin de chaque vidéo des choix
qui apparaissent à l'écran quand il ya
que deux choix
mais sinon ils seront tout le temps dans
la description en supplémentaire et je
vous conseille vivement de faire
laventure sur un ordinateur pc un mac
peu importe c'est beaucoup plus fluide
que sur mobile pour passer d'une vidéo à
l'autre parce que des fois ça ouvre
votre navigateur pour revenir sur
l'application youtube
donc vaut mieux le faire en vrai bien
posé devant un pc
on va commencer dans quelques secondes
n'oubliez pas de cliquer cette vidéo si
parce que à la fin de l' enquête vous
serez plus sur cette vidéo la et donc
pour le référencement c'est bon donc
n'hésitez pas à liker maintenant bonne
chance pour laquelle je compte sur vous
et bienvenue dans l' enquête
king ap
[Musique]